welcome back to new rock stars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about super soldier
puppets used by population controlling
governments
and whether or not cyclops knows his
eyes are mirrors to his soul
or another dimension yes that's right
he's got eyes he's got hungry eyes
shoot out lasers and it was a problem
for him in high school
and it was a problem for him in
adulthood and he never got over it and
that's what therapy that's why you go to
therapy you do the work you stop
shooting lasers at the people you love
anyway i'm tommy
[Laughter]
it'll help i'm here with my moon and
stars my queen my khaleesi my everything
jessica clemens hello jessica oh my gosh
i only want you to introduce me is that
every every time now
you can never introduce me as anything
else
star we're
i'm excited for this yes here we go
we're reversing roles last time uh
you asked the question and i did the
gabin this time i'm gonna ask you the
question
and of course of course of course we're
talking falcon
and winter soldier in the falcon and the
winter soldier
we're seeing how the government attempts
to use the symbol of captain america as
a form of pro-america propaganda
by installing u.s agent john walker as
the new cap
here in the real world the government
has a history of using propaganda to
build up support amongst its citizens
especially when it comes to engaging in
overseas conflict i'm looking at you dr
seuss
don't cancel i'm looking at you redfish
bluefish i'm looking at you am i one
fish two fish redfish bluefish but most
especially white fish
is the mcu government using u.s agents
as a form of propaganda
are we all buying war bonds without
knowing it all of this leads to my
question for you jessica
how is u.s agent john walker similar to
real propaganda the u.s government
has used in the past honestly this hot
topic of a discussion is no better of a
question for both of us to be answering
let me first start with what propaganda
is propaganda is the information
especially of a bias mislady nature
that is used to promote or publicize a
particular political cause
or point of view sit on that and
recognize how
a lot of this is familiar
that we see this all the time wait a
minute i watched a
animals commercial yesterday that told
me to
fight for them and i was radicalized by
nintendo
we can ruin animals but we cannot ruin
the tent do not ruin nintendo for them
okay sorry
i was ratified oh that's fine i don't
like go grab it i have i'm lactose
intolerant i can't even eat these things
but i eat them still garbage it is
it's not good okay i'm sorry okay okay
we need to get back
back on track again here we come again
with our
[ __ ] back on our [ __ ] we just
talked about what the definition of
propaganda is
so irritated with you okay
we want to look at how the united states
has used characters as propaganda in the
past so we can see how it
comes into play in the falcon and winter
soldier series let's start with one of
the most iconic figures that stands as a
symbol for the us government
that is uncle jesse psych i'm joking
it's uncle sam
um could you imagine if it was uncle
jessica forever
forever and i'm like you'll be a
patriot forever i'm literally standing
up
just like walking out the door my mom's
like jessica get back um no
uncle sam um and who i wish i figured
out today
is a actually a combination of two
characters yankee doodle a term from the
british army used for colonial soldiers
and brother jonathan an american
folklore hero who represented new
england
those two new england they suck just
kidding guys
is this about football football
someone was like someone was like
jessica you should wear
a tom brady jersey next time you do
anything with tommy
don't do that to me i thought it would
make you like mad funny but if it makes
you sad
funny i don't want you no no no no
it'll it'll make me mad funny oh my god
then i won
i don't like them either you guys i know
football i promise so
the character uncle sam first came to
prominence during war of 1812.
new york businessman sam wilson the same
name of the falcon
i don't know if you knew that provided
rations for soldiers on the front line
the soldiers fighting in the war
would see u.s stamped on the barrels of
food even though the u.s meant that the
rations were for the u.s
government property the soldiers would
say the food came from uncle sam
wilson which is really funny
all i imagine is if it said like it's
just like falcon's face on the food and
they're like
yeah wait a minute also i just like the
idea of a 1812 businessman
like what kind of like was he like
putting on his business suit and like
all right honey i gotta slick back my
hair
head down to wall street but he gets in
his little horse and buggy and rides
down to his office
oh my god tell me how for some reason
when i think of 1812 businessman i think
of like the stock market crash
like clip art of like a man with a
barrel
and suspenders and he's like honey i'm
going to work
i don't know why like that's all i think
he makes money but for some reason he's
still living in this barrel
that's all i think about the uncle sam
character had his look fully cemented
with world war one recruitment poster we
all know and love
created by jm flag in 1917 the
we want you that poster that has been
recreated
and is on video games and on posters and
everywhere you know you know the poster
the image of uncle sam has been used
heavily for mental
military recruitment in world war one in
world war ii and his personification
of the american spirit is a symbol that
promotes national pride and is
recognized around the world
it's important to remember that uncle
sam is a representation of the american
government
not his people which make him a unique
figure i wonder what they're gonna use
him for for world war three
they're like oh dude we already used him
like twice and i don't know if people
even like him anymore
we'll make a cryptocurrency for him sam
coin no no no
no no that's a scam i download the robin
hood app
immediately to see how much money i made
i don't use robin hood you guys
okay google google show me this guy's
balls please
okay how do i make cryptocurrency yeah
how do i make cryptocurrency i feel like
name something that's like sounds
illegal but isn't illegal i feel like
it's this
i don't i don't trust it i don't trust
it you guys
yes but this will be the world war three
version of it or it'll be like
tesla or something he'll be like the
face of tesla
oh god his cars uncle sam's cars sound
awful
um heather no thank you
beep beep belts everyone cruising on
that main street
you're relaxing feeling good
other countries have their own
characters that are personifications of
their government or citizens the french
republic has
marianne since the french revolution
she's been the personification of the
french republic
she has been depicted on currency the
official government logo monuments
through the country
postage stamps she's the official emblem
of the 2024
summer olympics in paris this [ __ ] is
already prepared to be on something and
it hasn't even started yet
she is an icon oh there's another one
okay so john bull
is the personification of england and is
usually a stout gentleman with a
waistcoat and tails
a top hat a cane and a fetching a vest
big winston churchill energy over here
this is the man i'm gonna draw mary
this is the man oh
more like john bull bang me
yes yeah john
just just cut just jump to john
paul
[Laughter]
i hate you so much
it's not it's a terrible joke that's a
porn star's name
what's your name john balls john balls
very smart like is there anything about
nah they're normal i just like to name
it
ironically ironically huge shaft small
balls
but he also comes in with a waistcoat
and tails a top hat
a cane and a fetching vest oh my
goodness hey i'm john
reading this out loud i was like this is
the one tommy's gonna fall in love with
this is the one that tommy's gonna be
like oh
i'm here for this guy yeah
well you had me at stout gentlemen i'll
tell you that
so the british also have and i excuse me
if i'm pronouncing this wrong
britannia britain britannia britannia
the female personification of britain
that's what britain
britain britannia yeah okay the female
personification of britain she is
traditionally a female warrior
with a trident and a dang shield
the first uses of britannia date back to
greek in roman times where she appeared
in art historical documents
and on coins she would kick my ass
brianna tarth who because britannia
i just need to say i need to set a quick
reminder all right calendar
bring me back to this webpage around
nine o'clock today
tommy thomas thomas i swear to god
john we we're stopping here i'm gonna
give you guys the rest because tommy's
gonna try having sex with every
every iconic character mary kill
uncle sam john balls and britannia and
let me tell you what
the anime the answer is britannia yeah
britannia for all three i was i will
marry john balls because then my name
will be jessica
uncle sam yeah kill uncles
well not even past the first one okay
russia okay so and the russians have
mother russia
derived from the slavic goddess and i'm
so sorry you guys i'm going to butcher
this and i'm going to try
mokash makash makish
i'll say mok oh my god i'm just going to
say mokash i'm so sorry
um mother russia is another female
warrior that was a symbol for the
russian people during many revolutions
in civil wars
she was also depicted heavily imprinted
in printed media with marianne and
brittany
britton britannia oh my gosh
a mouthful during the world war one as
three countries were allies during the
war
ooh don't look at the image
don't look at the image don't look at
the images don't throw those arms
stop it don't like it hashtag arm goals
you guys are looking into something we
shouldn't even be watching tommy b
wow honey look at those toes no the big
question was this could be me getting
turned down by statues today but here we
are
i can't take tommy to a museum you guys
that's why you can't take thomas museum
study abroad you can't he can't go he
can't do it
they are cool as hell though never
they're like are you okay you're
sweating looking at a bust
oh my no kidding i need a cigarette
after this take him away from this
computer
i can't even finish this and falcon
winners
soldier the us government could see the
symbol of captain america as more
important than actual person who wears a
suit
and that's probably why they don't care
that it's a nobody named john walker in
the series
this john walker is the like perfect
example for all of this propaganda
um and this is what makes me really
excited for falcon winter soldier
because we're getting into a part where
which i think vos already mentioned how
we
don't no one's really like bad
like there's no bad characters or like
evil characters it's people that are
like
they make sense they're like killmonger
like thanos it's like i get your plan it
makes sense it's justified
but you're doing it in a horrible way
right
right right at the cost of other human
lives yes
and that's why and i think this is gonna
be so fun to get into like now we're
getting into like american propaganda
and i'm like
you guys there's a lot of it all right
let's pile it on let's get out of here
that's a lot of propaganda oh okay oh so
go back there's another
okay so i left out the most iconic one
the number one that tommy's gonna love
more than any of them for pro war
propaganda was rosie the riveter
our girl our strong
do it we can we can and we
shall look at her
stop it i'm never going to click on the
image
meow treat yourself okay i'm going to
treat myself
treat yourself i'm going to treat myself
to this emmett
yep it's the we can do it poster you
guys
meow um we're doing exactly the opposite
of what she was meant to do
no i'm gonna say what sexualize her it's
her work ethic that turns me on
that's true sorry sorry sorry that's my
fault i was assuming wrong
you are a good man tommy you sexualize
the work ethic
is that isn't that what isn't that what
uh being a male feminist is sexualizing
work ethic right
i think you're completely wrong but go
on
i'm not gonna fix it but yeah you're
probably you're
a horrible man oh god the comments on
this one are gonna be
elected they're gonna oh my god the last
one was fun this one tommy's just a
monster
he's just really problematic we learned
hey you know sometimes it happens
um never meet your heroes guys i learned
an important lesson
you can't count on anyone rosie was
created during world war
ii to represent the women who worked in
the factories and shipyards as part of
the war effort as we
know women had to transition into new
jobs to fill in for the men who joined
the military
the term rosie the river came from a
1942 song of the same name written by
red
evans and john jacob loeb that's a
banger go
get it on your spotify do you listen to
that song that's in your top
that's it that was on your spotify like
that's all i listened to
that might be a good song to work out
too i'd be into that
i'm gonna listen to it right after this
and if it's not good i'm
to blame you for it she's making history
working for victory rosie
the identity of the real rosie the
riveter on whom the song is based is
debated to be one of three women
all with the same version of the name
rosie
i.e rosie not e-y rosie or
rose only the ie rosies are the good
ones the
eys are evil i think i've never met a
rosie with an ey
but if you are one i'm not gonna like
fight you
but maybe who knows contact us on social
media tell us about yourself
yeah do a interview to see if i'll kick
your ass
jesse don't do it norman rockwell
painted a picture of rosie the riveter
for the cover of the saturday evening
post in 1943 that became wildly popular
this image was not used much after the
war due to the rockwell
state's iron grip on the copyright the
rock
we're not even gonna get into the
rockwells we're not even gonna get
into the rockwells talk about propaganda
talk about yes bad art bad bad art
oh my god troubling images out of that
out of that estate
troubling images indeed you heard it
here first folks i
hate the rockwells did it work
rosie's effect on women joining the
workforce was real she inspired a social
movement that increased the number of
women working
by 57
that is ins okay so they went to 57
and a change in public perception about
what types of jobs women could do
which is so cool you know that's great
get women
in there give them jobs and then of
course we
turn that [ __ ] upside down we turn that
ship
we take it we turn into the titanic it
hits the freaking
iceberg and then the iceberg says well
what happens when men come back
from the war they should have their jobs
and exactly that's what happened
i hate to sound unpatriotic but i think
america's uh
official slogan for the country should
just be
psych fight it should be it should be it
should be
whenever we need people to do stuff
we're like guys pull yourselves up by
your food strips we can all do
we're in this together but then the
second it becomes inconvenient for the
people in power they're like
psych put those bootstraps right back
down and go hide in your house
if they could have like literally
instead of like on the
money on the dollar bill underneath it
just says my bee because they just
they're like whatever is whatever
happens you know
it just says [ __ ] happens and i'm like
what do you mean [ __ ] happens
i lost my job and so literally
these women went into work were super
happy was like i have jobs we can live
without men and then when the men came
back
they got kicked out of their jobs the
government even rolled out
new propaganda urging women to go back
to working at home
and a return to normalcy literally and
you know you can already ima
imagine i'm not going to post a photo
imagine what that propaganda it's gonna
be like
a woman in front of an oven and it's
like don't you miss it
you are warm here and it's like
i was warm this is rosie the relaxer
this is
she's just like with a newspaper and
like a t and i'm like what are you guys
doing psych
like they are just a bunch of frat boys
they straight up did that to us
i say do that to us i wasn't there but i
am a woman you guys
yes i go by the sheer pronouns but
the government couldn't put the genie
back in that damn bottle
rosie would go to become an icon of
american feminism
and women's economic advantage the most
famous image of rosie the river came
from the poster made by j howard miller
in 1942 the famous
we can do it poster tommy's favorite
poster in the world
he loves it more than his scarface
poster that sits above his bed every
night i took my scarface poster down
i put my rose of the riveter poster up i
took pictures of my family down
i put my pictures of marianne and uh
mother russia
it's just oh it's all uh propaganda
pictures for me i'm in my room now are a
true feminist and i love you for that
i love that that's like the changing of
a boy to a man is taking down the
scarface poster and putting the rosie
the riveter one up
it's just like my son he knows today i
became a man
he takes down his like quinn tarantino
all the posters for queen tarantino
movies and then just puts up like
zoe saldana like hey beyonce i'm like
i'm proud of you
good job it was just a morale boosting
poster created by the westinghouse
electric corporation
um and was shown to employees for two
week period in 1943 and then lost to
history
it wasn't until the poster was
rediscovered in the 1980s that it became
repurposed as a feminism icon
and mistakenly labeled as rosie the
riveter
but that's it that's a fun fact and by
the way canada had their own rosie
and ronnie the bren gun girl click on it
click on it
yes ronnie the bread gun girl
rolls off the tongue just like rosie the
riveter um i love her
she's iconic ronnie the bread gun girl
wait a second
wait a second rosie is a great example
also of how the government can use
propaganda for its intended effect
but the people can ultimately repurpose
that icon and have it take
on a whole new meaning so basically 110
what john walker is going to be doing
and falcon winner soldier it's
clearly like this is the people's
captain america versus
captain america who became like it
wasn't that captain america became like
a bad
guy it was just that he was like
questioning society and like the
systemic problems that were hitting
america
whereas john walker is like no there is
no problem
a lot of the propaganda symbols we've
mentioned were important during world
war ii
when there was a massive effort by the
government to create propaganda
in 1942 as the us involvement in ww2 was
getting into full swing
the government created the office of war
information also known as
owi uh that oversaw the government's
propaganda by recruiting artists
filmmakers storytellers and
intellectuals aka tommy bech told
as part of a huge effort to ensure that
the american people supported the war
effort
tommy's in there typing
zombies going crazy in that room
it's a lot of crude drawings of you with
giant tanks for arms
uh i don't think we can use those mr
beck told why did you draw boobs on this
tank
i don't think the statue of liberty is
supposed to be
uh drawn in that position mr bechtol
that was
very inappropriate you're like this is
murder they're like damn he has a way
with words he just wishes
he gets right to it he just gets
straight to it
you know what i love that guy i'll vote
for that guy going back to our last big
question
i'll vote for that guy he should run the
free world um the owi created newsreels
posters pamphlets radio shows and films
they also utilize media that already
existed
and to help spread the pro-war message
including comic book characters like
superman captain america
owner of america's ass that is america's
ass
they are they straighter
we talking cakes we talking it's a full
bakery
i'm shook i can't finish the rest of
this episode
it's a full bakery of ass
don't mind if i do sponsored by the good
old usma
they got that's how they're going to get
me i'm going back oh i was learned by
the ass factory
united states of ass god they got me
they got me they knew i loved ass so
much so
joe simon conceived
he stopped joe simon conceived captain
america in the 1940s
and the first issue of cap punching
hitler on the cover hit shelves in
december of 1940
a year before pearl harbor once america
entered world war
ii propaganda posters featuring captain
america were used to inspire the public
into supporting the troops
planting victory gardens buying war
bonds
you know things captain america does all
the time
um troops fighting overseas were sent
captain america comic books in order to
boost morale
the americans always won in the comics
oh that's nice hey boys go risk your
life
he's a fun here's a fun time i'm
literally like i'm so hungry and they're
like
that's what is coming it's also not the
full issue you only get the first 10
pages
you can take some money out of your own
pay and then buy the rest of these comic
books
yeah you can open another chapter
that's why i was like that's absolutely
how it went
the real history was recreated in the
mcu with captain america starting out as
propaganda machine
before he could take on red skull and
hydra the government had him
singing and dancing to bring in the cash
you remember when he was
the america's little monkey for a minute
uh
in that in that tattered outfit uh
the propaganda machine can swing both
ways and just as much as the us dished
it out propaganda was often used against
american troops fighting overseas
during world war ii the korean war and
the vietnam war radio broadcast from
english-speaking broadcasters targeted
american troops with the goal of
diminishing morale and making u.s
question their reasons for fighting wow
they really held up a mirror to us wow
we truly and we we stayed the broadcast
would feature made-up stories about
american soldiers refusing to fight or
surrendering on the battlefield because
they didn't believe in the war
sometimes the broadcast revealed the
names of the soldiers in their movements
or locations in an effort to scare the
listeners that's
what that's great how'd they get that
information yeah
wait a minute who gave them from the
headlines that's terrifying
that's also to re get a newspaper in a
different country that you're like the
headline for i'd be like
yeah wait a minute there's a
there must be another jessica clements
here because i i didn't do anything
i've been literally at the base i've
been reading this comic book for the
last three days this isn't about me
i've been crying into the pages of this
very optimistic comic book
i've been eating this stuff
it's i feed them they don't need just
oats
they're not horses they're people okay
no okay i'm sorry tommy um some of the
more famous propaganda radio
personalities over the years were axis
sally
lord
[Laughter]
aristocrat i want that name
but also if i think of the name i'm lord
haha
why would he be fancy he would be fancy
there's lord haha his name is literally
a punchline
and this is my wife lady hehehe
[Laughter]
damn this seems too weird i don't like
this [ __ ] um
han noy hannah and tokyo rose
these names were well known among the
soldiers who would often hear the radio
broadcast
this is like uh good morning vietnam
why did they put his name on here he
should be on this list yeah
um and also robin williams bet you
didn't know
um bringing this back to falcon winter
soldier there's a reason the government
is sending out u.s agent john walker as
captain america instead of sam
bucky sure there are issues making
samurai bucky as the new cap they both
have recent criminal history
institutional racism is still persistent
in the government
let me we'll get into this the
possibility that bucky is still
programmed to be
literally a soviet killing machine fair
play
i thought about that when they first
were like yeah let's make bucky the
winter soldier i was like
oh let's make him like the new captain
america and i was like i would love that
but like
if you splurt out like seven random
things of code and they're all
correct he will turn into a war machine
like he'll be back yeah i i don't want
to i don't want to shame him
but like no he's a sleeper agent like he
literally will kill everybody
um go ahead and make anthony mackie but
again institutional racism is a real
thing and i don't know
how happy they would be um could they be
trying to win the us population's favor
during a larger conflict
they definitely in this series are
definitely going to just be like
the people aren't that they don't they
can be easily entertained
like let's just bring out fireworks and
a blonde man
and kurt russell's son who is fine as
hell
and jessica clemens will be like i'm
voting for him
he brought fireworks and he has a nice
butt his butt's going to be thicker
than captain america's and that's what
i'm like god damn it's a baking factory
it's not just a bakery
so it's a warehouse i just want to know
those buns
i just want to need them buns like a cat
i just get my claws in them this is such
a gross podcast
i want
[Laughter]
i don't know why i imagine this is me
coming at him are you like keyboard cat
i'm
oh it is it's reading sexy to me you
said i was the keyboard cat
the one that's going on
the keyboard cat is to me the height of
sexuality
so you okay so you're like romantically
interested in garfield
put that shirt on
i'm like i don't know why i'm offended
but i am not the damn
cat playing the keyboard
i'm the sexy cat that goes yeah you're
the sexy cat
that doesn't play
i scat that's better than playing the
keyboard
what's more sexy than scatting okay and
are they trying to push people to doing
the equivalent of buying war bonds
probably well mcu does not stray from
war bonds for sure
we'll find out more about exactly why
the government needs captain america
and they can fully puppeteer but for now
we can be sure that it's because they
want to get the support of the american
people behind
whatever military effort they're going
to pull next and oh my gosh that's the
end of my little thing
that's the end of ours we didn't even
get to get into the weird prop
the weird my propaganda oh you have
personal propaganda yes
i probably do that's weird i'm i'm
always like come to my twitch i'll give
you
candy um i don't do that i wear wigs
though so i think people are like
my propaganda's wigs oh wigs are your
problems
what would be my propaganda probably all
the catfishing accounts i have on dating
apps that would be my
it's definitely that well i mean is it
working because does that
make it not propaganda they're not
working no i don't think it's propaganda
if it's not working
i'm extremely lonely just jessica you
told me if it's working
like yeah you take a look at my life and
tell me if you think things are stopping
working here
stop it all right we're gonna dive into
our
bite size questions next but first a
word from some of the folks
that help us bring you big question
saving money is at the top of everyone's
resolution list for me
it goes lose a little weight reunite
with my family
meet my birth father take jesus christ
into my heart a little more
and saving money is number five so stop
paying insane amounts of money every
month for wireless
you idiots as the first company to sell
premium wireless service online only
mint mobile maximizes your savings with
plans starting at just
fifteen dollars a month so for one cup
of starbucks coffee
you can get a mobile plan and i'm
talking the really i'm talking the fancy
like the unicorn latte or whatever that
thing was that came with
whipped cream and sprinkles those
expensive ones because it's a little
more it's like two and a half cups
anyway here at new rock stars phillips
switched to mint mobile
and he loves it i don't wouldn't know
that because he won't return my calls
and when i text him he says wrong number
please stop texting he saves more than
20 bucks a month from his old plan
and he gets to use a 5g network which he
holds over my head
is kind of a tech flex you know i'm on
four g's
some people they only get three g's but
philip he's a 5g
for good good gangster all right
mint mobile offers premium wireless for
as little as 15
bucks a month all plans come with
unlimited talk and text so gab gab
gab to your girlfriends your boyfriends
and all your friends
in between on that beautiful spectrum we
call life
okay high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network
use your own phone with any mint mobile
plan and keep your same phone number and
existing contacts wouldn't that be crazy
if they were like delete all your
contacts
mint mobile is a fresh start you'll make
new friends
you'll find new lovers with mint mobile
and let me tell you something guys
you take a look in the mirror and you're
not 100 satisfied with what you see
meant mobile has nothing to do with that
but when you go to your phone
and you're not 100 satisfied mint mobile
has a seven day money back guarantee you
get a calendar week to decide
if this is the phone plan for you or
they'll ship that money right back to
you so to get your new wireless plan for
just 15 bucks a month
and get the plan shipped to your door
for free go to mittmobile.com
big q that's mintmobile.com
bigq cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks
a month at mittmobile.com
big q all right folks
i want to talk to you now a little bit
about masterclass masterclass
lets you learn from the world's best
minds anytime
anywhere at your own pace learn how to
dj from quest love
improve your storytelling skills with
neil gaiman or
learn writing for television from shonda
rhimes i have a master class and how to
sleep in on important days when you have
things
it's called deflecting responsibility
and self-sabotage with tommy beck told
you well they can't
they can't not give you the job because
of your own merits if you don't get the
job because you never showed up guys
alright
that's a free little bit of my master
class anyway with over 100 classes from
a range of world-class instructors
that thing you always want to do is
closer than you think unless it's murder
there is no murder master class just
watch netflix like a psychopath at new
rockstars we've been digging some of the
filmmaking master classes from directors
like spike lee
and david lynch i call him davey lynch
and he tells me not to do that
they even got an acting class from jane
foster herself natalie portman
she doesn't go into a ton of detail
about how to act like the aether is
getting sucked out of you
but she does cover a lot of good
material and she has an oscar
now again if you want to hear more about
things getting sucked out of you go to
my master class because we talked about
that for an hour and a half
just different things that have been
sucked out of me over the years
masterclass is accessible on your phone
web
or smart tv each class is broken out
into individual video lessons usually
around 10 minutes long members can
explore at their own pace
and each class is supported by
downloadable materials like lessons and
recipes
oh that's right i didn't even mention
you can take a cooking class from gordon
ramsay
or wolfgang puck or just post a tick
tock of yourself making scrambled eggs
and gordon ramsay roast you for free all
right
you can find all available classes at
masterclass.com
i highly recommend you check it out get
unlimited access to every masterclass
and as a big question viewer
you get 15 off an annual membership go
to masterclass.com
bigquestion that's masterclass.com
big questions for 15 off masterclass and
now it's time for a bite-sized question
bite size question who has the more
powerful laser beam
iron man's unibeam cyclops optic blast
or superman's heat vision said
nugget fiend on twitter nugget fiend wow
none of these powers or abilities are
laser beams by definition
but i understand the spirit of the
question
so let's break these heroes down shall
we
iron man starting with our boy tony
stark the unibeam is a particle weapon
on iron man's chest
and more powerful version of his hand
repulsors it's directly linked to the
ark reactor and has been modified to
fire highly concentrated
repulsor blasts the version of the
unibeam on the mark 46 armor was
able to disintegrate the winter
soldier's titanium arm
damn however tony always has to make
sure the unibeam is used sparingly
because it drains a lot of power it's a
briefly powerful but
finite weapon just like me briefly
powerful
oh wait a minute wait a minute i thought
that was cute at first now i know what
you mean and it's gross
no no no i meant it the cute way cyclops
no you didn't
let's talk cyclops i bet it cute i meant
it cute
cyclops cyclops is able to generate
concussive
force-based red-colored beams from his
eyes
the optic blasts are caused by portals
in his eyes that connect to a different
dimension
that continually releases the red
kinetic energy what kind of dimension is
that by the way
but he's just it's just all it's just
all red energy
anyway you go into it
it burns uh according to the comics
they don't generate any heat even from
friction
though this is commonly forgotten as
he's been shown to light birthday
candles before so i guess
it's just whatever like most comic books
his powers are whatever they need to be
to move the story along
in the x-men film age of apocalypse
cyclops
does split charles xavier's favorite
tree in half
and it can be seen burning and smoking
but this is wrong
does that mean i'm expelled his maximum
output has been rated at two gigawatts
the equivalent output of a large-scale
nuclear reactor he's also blown the top
off a mountain
so that's pretty powerful next my pale
soups clark kent superman kell
the last son of krypton superman's heat
vision is a superpower possessed by
kryptonians
when exposed to the yellow sun he has
the ability to release
massive amounts of solar energy stored
within the body
through his eyes in focused beams of
heat presumably
as infrared light in the dc eu
superman has an invisible form of his
focused radiation that can quickly super
heat any substance like a microwave
melt it can also melt thick layers of
ice and cauterize flesh
hello when he really lets loose those
fiery orange invisible beams
superman can cut through the toughest
metals superman's eyes melt steal beams
you conspiracy
uh anyway superman can cut through the
toughest metal
and while he can't slice through fellow
kryptonian zod with them he can cause
him intense burning pain
so that's kind of nice we're not sure
how hot superman can make his heat
vision because
science is unable to accurately measure
it because he's not a real person and
you guys need to repossess your life
priorities
if you think this science is real cut
that part out i don't want to hurt
people's feelings
uh in the comics he's been able to burn
up an entire planet and go toe-to-toe
with darkseid's omega energy so that's
pretty powerful
it's understandable that it's very very
powerful but put him in a windowless
room and deny him some yellow sun and
he's got
nothing just like me put me in a
windowless room deny me the sun and i
stopped making music
uh if all three movie versions of these
characters were to meet up
cyclops might be able to take the cake
here with the you know
mountain blasting eyes yeah that can
blow a mountaintop off
that's right so uh you know what i
always say
get toxic in the comments and fight with
each other about who this is but i'm
going with yeah
so do mary kill with cyclops iron man
and superman i really need to know these
but they're not lasers
yes but they're not amazing no
they're just hotter than a microwave
they're portals to another dimension
he can take me to that dimension not
cyclops not cyclops
yeah but henry cavill super he is a
doofus that's why
that is it truly when i when people are
like he's attractive i think of how much
of like a goof he is and i'm like
no he's not he's a little butthole
are we ready for a little box of stuff
do it
it's time for the boxes
say one more time box
i love that oh okay okay
okay tommy i got a box of scraps
question for you with a box of scraps
what big popular fandom do you feel like
you've never been able to get into
before you
before even though you've tried oh
so you know i but back when people were
allowed to socialize in person
i can contended i attended a lot of uh
comic cons
different comic cons all over the
country uh
giving my gift of nerd knowledge and
comedy everywhere i went
but uh there was one fandom that i just
never could get involved
in uh in no matter how hard i try it's
something very important to a lot of my
friends it's something that they
do they reference they dress up like a
lot
they do improv shows basically the
answer is
doctor who i i just don't get it i tried
to watch
it it didn't connect with me i've i've
watched at least one episode with every
doctor except the woman one because i'll
never accept her as a doctor
because she's a girl god i knew it
you're so problematic
i sensed it the fan sensed it
kidding kidding of course but i uh
i yeah no i just don't like doctor who
i'm sorry it's not i don't like it i
just don't i just it doesn't it doesn't
resonate with me i'm not into it
uh you can cancel me all you want for
many things that are way worse than this
opinion but
i the truth must be known i am not a
doctor who guy
what about you i'm trying to think about
it because i can get into like
everything at a
like a minimum because like doctor who i
i haven't finished it but i did watch
like three of the doctors and i liked it
i just didn't finish it
um so i guess like one that i don't get
like
i'm looking around my room to see what's
the opposite of what i don't like
um i don't go crazy oh
i don't go crazy for fast and the
furious oh yeah
i don't like fast and the furious tried
to watch it didn't like it
don't understand cars only love
ludicrous
right he is the best part of those he's
the best he is the best part of those
movies
i i was like truly trying to think of
what's the opposite of what i watch and
i was like i can't do
any of the fast and furious things if
you took me to a fast and furious
convention
no there's there is a fast and the
furious convention no but i could just
oh it might
be this beach and it's just where every
bald man
in venice beach beat up you just go to
venice beach and yo
firmly and they're all running at you
and they go
with their muscle cars you hear them
coming from like 20
like minutes away oh my god i would not
want to be in mine during that
no no my nephew refers to vin diesel as
dominic toretto and nothing else he
won't even like acknowledge
that vin diesel's in other movies he
just idolizes
dominic you know he doesn't he's like
that's dominic toretto does the voice of
groot but i love that he says the full
name too
but he has the full name when he came
out here to visit we took him to
universal studios and they have the fast
the furious part is the end of the movie
tour and he
i mean vindy's was not even there it's
just a video of him and it was like
i think he was legitimately nervous to
see his image like he was like
maybe he'll somehow sense i'm here but i
do i don't
i can't oh my god i love that so much
that touches my heart
now i feel bad but those movies are
overrated
they yeah i love everyone in it don't
get me wrong it's just that i'm like
you can just you can go so fast in cars
you know and it
gets me every time it's like not really
like it's like cars and science
kind of but it's not really they defy
logic and gravity
they're just you know i think they are
good for what they are which is like
two and a half hours of excitement or
two hours yeah you know explosions and
chases and if that's what you're in the
mood for
god bless you but if you're a man like
me a man of substance
a man of uh of deep artistic need
then watch something with a little more
depth to it okay maybe
a kurosawa film maybe go and see what uh
watch some old westerns done by italian
men i don't know tommy wants you to put
on gotham
and watch every season and every episode
watch season one and two of gotham
and then look at my my drawings of uh
jim gordon
and uh and various uh characters it
embraces it's just a hugging jim gordon
series
is jim gordon your favorite character i
feel like
yes because i love well because yeah
he's everything i love he's a cop
and i love the police and he has a
mustache
i just think he's funny i thought okay
never mind i guess
i'm wrong i got mine no i'm just kidding
what do you mean i like jim gordon that
was funny i didn't i didn't mean to not
yes and that
i am i i like jim gordon i do actually
like jim gordon
you know what i really like is the guy
who plays him
ben mckenzie i'm a better gotham
yeah oh okay i was like there's a lot of
people that play
gary just the one guy who played it it's
not the same actor and all the movies
no not even in this in the animated
series you're telling me it's not that
guy too
no i thought they were all ben mckenzie
no they're not
i'm so sorry well speaking of fast and
furious we're going to fast and
furiously move on from my faux pas
and that's it for this episode of big
question oh my god we learned so much
we had fun we learned a little we
learned a lot
we said some things we meant we said
some things we didn't mean but by all
means don't
try and discern what was what don't look
for subtly don't look for nuance just
react knee-jerk in the comments
whatever you feel first is the right
thing if you're upset about it
don't search for any layers just come at
me all right
thank you don't listen to tommy you guys
he's
it's funny tommy says that he is a white
man and i am a black female
do not do that dude yeah you know come
at us
come out with your first instinct no
don't don't don't i'm kidding
of course please please don't i'm just
like please
completely nice to us and if you're mean
to jessica i will find you
i'm gonna dox everyone that's mean to me
i i will personally put a virus on all
of your computers that just
say naughty boy because i'm sure you're
all men when it comes up
all right that's it for this episode of
the big question thank you jessica for
joining me this episode my god
i'd go to the end of the earth for you
follow her at lulu clemens follow me at
tommy bechtold follow new rockstars
send us your big questions using the
hashtag bigquestion
subscribe to this podcast feed and give
us a nice rating and review
subscribe to new rockstars here on
youtube hit that notification bell baby
let us know what you think if it's nice
if it's not
take it and cram it in your pocket and
save it for an eric boss video
we love you very much goodbye jessica
goodbye
[Music]
you